hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
this is big dave hi everyone
we are around his massive commercial to
residential site
this this is going to be seven
apartments is that right that's right
yeah bought for 125 000 pounds
the gdv once it's finished is going to
be about half a million being
conservative right yeah let's have a
look around we'll show you the figures
let's go
so this property was an office yeah
and you are turning it into residential
yeah so there's going to be
seven apartments in total yeah seven one
bedroom apartments have been being
converted into here
yeah so this property was self-sourced
by a client of ours
um but she didn't have the knowledge to
do the builds you just wanted a second
opinion
we've worked with her very well in the
past so yeah she actually picked this up
you know 425
000. yes correctly priced oh 425
000. but the amount of movement in the
property
people put off with it they weren't
unsure but then obviously we
solved that problem so obviously that's
one thing it's about though it's about
finding a problem solving the problem so
basically so you had a friend or a
client
who found this negotiated for 125 grand
knew the potential for it you could see
this could be seven beautiful apartments
it could have been worth half a million
pound or more but
the structural issues there's movement i
don't know
i'm out of my depth here so what did you
arrange them with your client how did
you apart from doing the development
you've done this as a joint venture
how did that work yeah so with this
particular client she came to us
and she wanted the knowledge and how to
put it all together how to get over the
structural issues
then obviously with project management
so we've assisted on that one
and yes we are making profit but it's
not as much profit
okay so we make a little bit at the end
but then we've joined veterans made a
bit of an income every calendar month on
it
so we just put ourselves into a bit of a
rent so that that's where you're smart
though david because
most most builders will just want to be
you know they want to charge their fee
and then move on to next job what you're
doing is you're
continually building for yourself a
passive income on top yeah it's all
about it's thinking outside the box it's
um that's what i like to do
yeah i do like using other people's
money as well as mine but
um yes think think about logically how
what you can give back
best joint venture partners really is
where you can help each other
and once you've got that relationship
yeah you won't go far right are you
are you very interested in passive
income is that something that you're
building yeah definitely
but most builders don't get that no it's
passive income to me yeah your business
is earning money
yeah yeah i've got you know i've got two
businesses and yeah they're both making
income
yeah so i've got focus holdings you know
and i've got focus projects development
so one's refurbishment one source inside
of it as well
and so they marry quite well and then
i've got my own portfolio as well
uh to one side so it makes a nice little
pot so your companies are making you an
income but also you've got a passive
income
do you do you ever do i'm sure you do
deals because i've
often looked for bills to do this kind
of thing with i've got a project
the builder will come in and do the
refurb and instead of me having to pay
for builders they'll do it and they'll
pay for the materials but then
they'll just have a stake in the
property forever that's right that's
another way of doing joint venture
why don't more builders do that god
knows i'm going to close it so
if i was a builder i would be solely
doing that i've been like look i'll work
for free
yeah you know i'll work for free but i
want to stake in the property yeah
it's you know joint ventures people
builders to me tradesmen
yeah i'm a tradesman myself but it's
very few and far between they actually
open their eyes and see the potential in
a property
yeah you know they have to it's all
comes about education
if builders got educated properly and
they knew what they could do and achieve
well to me why not it's you go and do
that kind of thing
do you think as well a lot of builders
they're really good at the
the trade side but they just don't know
how to actually think like an
investor and they're making money the
entrepreneur side they are missing
yeah a lot of businesses would
especially trade when i fell into the
trap myself
where yeah you're very in your business
you're working in your business so
yeah you're very heavily working on
tools you're building things
yeah and they're not they don't have
time to think of other incomes because
they're too busy in the business
this is the last one to be done so the
last bathroom is being tiled now in here
a bit of a holding room obviously we've
got all health and safety ups all your
first aid which you need to
that's always a good sign of when using
the right contractors make sure they're
all
they've got the right stuff hasn't got
the health and safety in place you know
you've got your first day lined up
if you walk onto a site and you feel a
bit iffy usually nine times out of ten
they're not the right contractor for you
so
it's just like little things like that
what's going to be in here bathroom yeah
so it's all coming together so this is a
complete like
re-gutting kind of job oh you've gone
back to near brickwork in some areas
yeah
i mean it's been how long of a project
like six months yeah so we've got plenty
approved in december um obviously
just before the christmas break so we're
doing site preparation on that one but
work started at the back end of january
on this development so now what we in
you know coming to
mid-august yeah so we're looking
mid-september
it doesn't look like it but no i can see
that this is almost ready it's nearly
there and this is this is one of the
roughest the others are all
yeah so but once you've finished if you
pull out all your money even if you have
to leave in 10
10 grand you've got seven apartments i
know we'll talk a little bit later about
how you're going to vent those out
you're going to rent those out very
nicely
so this is a great a great little deal
really it's um
it's it's all come together and knitted
quite well in this but it's and when you
took this place on it was offices wasn't
it
yeah it used to be a pub and then it
went to offices and then
and the office companies went under and
decided to sell on
no no one was interested weren't even on
the market there was enough market deal
this one
and but people weren't interested
because the major subsidies went didn't
know what they were
attacking shall we say so with the right
people and the right connections it's
all about your network what you've got
once you've got your network
you can put anything back together and
with subsidence people are not wanting
to touch it that's where someone like
you who's got the knowledge the
experience comes in because
as a successful property developer it's
about finding problems
yeah and then thinking more how much is
it going to cost me to fix that problem
whereas most people see a problem and
they'll either run or get burned by it
yeah so
it's like through my company anyhow it's
like i have a little saying say we don't
have problems only solutions
sounds really corny but it's true it's
all about the network of people you've
got
you know with my network which i've got
we're a team there's no individuals
we're a full team so everyone takes the
credit
of you know of the product at the end
and that's the way it should be that's
great
all right show us more yeah so it's what
literally
all of these one two three four the
whole building right yeah that's right
nice i can't believe one two five that
is absolutely and we're not in a poor
area
it's dug and broke it's not the best
part of action underlying where you're
based but
it's um it's the up and coming a lot of
regenerations going on around this area
great all right take us around what's up
here what's up here is that another
apartment
so up there there's another apartment so
these were we can see these little dots
yeah that's where it's been underpinned
so this is the elevation to get rid of
all these structural problems that's
right so all this stuff yeah so
stage by stage you've got dug out you
know underpinned
and and so forth so yes so just talk to
talk me through
when someone's got structural uh damage
should you run away from that or what i
mean obviously you don't mind you're
you're happy how difficult is it to fix
something with structural problems
because i know a lot of people
as soon as they hear the word structural
they're going to run them out no it's um
it's all about using your network so
obviously we use a
lot of structural engineers yeah so
obviously if we see something with a
structural problem then what we'll do
we'll actually
invite them down give a report done and
see how easy it can be fixed
so yeah it might be a bit of outlay at
the beginning but then today the rewards
could be quite good as well so it's
always a bit of a risk for structural
but that's the sound of everything if
you've got damn
go and get a damp survey if you've got
japanese not with go and get an expert
to go in
and you might lose a few hundred pounds
because it might be oh it's terrible
but i'd rather lose a few hundred pounds
but then make tens of thousands of
pounds exactly
in the in the deal itself so obviously
as you as you know we do many things
within our business
and we have a pot of money so yes okay
with any investment there's a risk
but ended it's minimizing your risk but
i prefer spending an extra
two three five thousand pound to get the
right survey done
yeah to get the rewards fair enough you
may get stung and it won't come good but
then today it's a risk it's a thousand
pounds the same as when i see people
going to auctions
and they don't want to get a survey
because they think oh probably won't get
the house
but you can't bid on a property without
having a survey it's madness
no you see a lot of you know yourself
with a lot of new investors coming on
the market
they see a lot of tv programs and
they've not been you know they've not
been educated properly
don't get wrong i'm all self-taught
majority of my stuff but
it's all about getting the right
knowledge fill your head with knowledge
and the way you go but
use your network your key parts using
your network yeah great
all right so obviously that's all been
underpinned on that elevation so we'll
just go upstairs into this platform
here so how is this is this how they're
going to get into the flat would you
stay
yes so each one has got each flat's got
its own entrance
okay so there's no communal spaces it's
a bit quieter in here
that's where you can tell with the
acoustics yeah doing the magic they're
doing the stuff so
talk to me david talk to me about the
acoustics because you've done a lot with
the sound here
cranky a lot of people don't
underestimate
the value of the acoustics then if you
don't get your acoustics passed
building control won't sign off on it so
you can either make or break your deal
so as you can see sorry it sounds so
minor because you think who cares about
the sound but it's not about the tenor
and the rentabilities actually you say
about the building control it is
you know it's like all our projects have
got building control we use a
third-party independent
company for that and yeah you have to
think of your your acoustics your fire
especially means everything has to be 60
minutes
some areas have to be you know 90
minutes so it's an hour and a half
it's things like that where people don't
really pay enough attention to
so it's like i said before as you'd feel
on the floor it's a bit full me that
absorbs impact it's nice
yeah so what we have to do as well is
when it comes to this stage when
everyone's offside i'll shut the site
for two days
then i'll get an acoustic testing
company to come and do their bit
now what they'll do is call the tap test
so basically like a hammer it's in the
floor
and they'll go around with a monitor to
see how much noise they're coming
through
so that's what they'll do so they'll
work all the numbers out to expand and
then
that will do for me as soon as i get
that certificate squeaky bum time's over
for me i've done my job so that's it
right so this this will be what this
will be our bedroom or this is going to
be
a kitchen our kitchen kitchen across
there and then basically kitchen living
room area
so it's plenty enough size so um in
teams high council where you are at
present
one bedroom apartments have to be no
less than 37 square meters which is
more than adequate yeah and how hands-on
do you get yourself because i know
you've got a good team
yeah you still do you do you plaster do
you do the hands-on stuff or do you
plaster your power plaster
from loving them so that's the one area
where i'm probably better than you then
when it comes to who knows let's have a
look
at the competition that's it but no it's
um i'ma join a carpenter by trade and um
i do saturday you know just gone i was
helping the lads because the job was
behind
i'm not going to get my hands dirty no
cry so this is me
what you get is what you know what you
see what you get with me and um yeah
what do you enjoy more do you enjoy the
investment side more because i know
you're an investor as well as a builder
developer
or do you prefer the actual seeing a
project come to fruition like what is it
that really makes you tick
i like seeing the end product so this
when i saw it at the beginning
and then to the end result you know in a
month's time or five weeks time when we
get it completed
that's when i'm like yeah that's when i
take pride
you know it's then it's going to turn
out to look every credit goes to the
labs you know we've got for a few drinks
to eat just to say thank you very much
for all the hard work so that basically
seeing the jobs come together
and working with investors you know it's
like everyone
everyone every investor is different and
we only work with a select few we don't
work with everyone because we can't
please everyone
so we're just quite happy just being
working with a select few so
where people go out and interview
contractors i was saying okay well what
words can you do and you go and go and
see their work
i do exactly the same through the
investor so it's a case of right okay
you tell me what you want
and i feel if it's going to work then
we'll start working together but
sometimes i'm not bothered how much
money you've got
it's a case of right i can work with you
because you might only have like fifty
thousand pounds i'll try and help that
work with you
i'd rather work with people like that
who's willing to make an effort than
someone who's really cash rich and just
going well i can sit back and
just rule the roost and try and dictate
we're gonna clash very soon so
[Music]
on the academy group i see all the time
posting another deal another deal about
getting
you know it's all about getting the
brand getting the name out there that's
why i do it
you know i'm not i'm not the most
photogenic yes i am overweight and he's
what you see is what you get with me but
a lot of people appreciate that we're
based up in manchester yes
and people know i'm just a straight
talking you're a big guy
with big knowledge and a big heart well
i wouldn't say that but every day is
learning
it for you yeah no but i don't i don't
think
i've come across anybody um on the
academy that's doing as many deals as
you're doing
and albeit sometimes that might be for
clients but it's impressive
and that's why i just wanted to i wanted
to interview you and get you on the
channel
because i think i don't know anybody
that
would be able to spend a day with you
and not learn
a lot about problem solving yeah it's
you know it's we've got this one which
is
you know at the moment it's our biggest
one and we've got what three going
through sales at the moment so we've got
one little
road which is like two miles away that's
going to be converted into a six bedroom
six all on suites
that's going through sale then we do a
lot with the social housing where we get
long leases attached to them
so basically it's a full hands-on thing
i want to say about social housing so i
know some of your investors
um sometimes we've got big hearts and
want to help people they
they want their houses to be socially
housed to help vulnerable people
people that might be on the on the
poverty line but also as a business
strategy
it's not really a bad it's not really
about strategy isn't it no so i've got
with my portfolio i've got a couple of
social housing uh
underway as well and they're all signed
up on like seven year leases with a bolt
on them in extra three years
and basically they just everyone you see
every every month he's used money coming
in ticking and taking him so
it worked really well i personally feel
it's a good strategy
especially over the kobe situation you
may have a lot of landlords out there
who've come a bit unstuck and
and they've taken a bit of a hint hit on
the rent or you know they've got a lot
of voids
you know i've always shouted to my
clients i don't want social housing yet
it may not be the best returns in the
world
but if you want continuity happy days
the thing is that you say that but it's
not even bad returns
i've had some of my hmos and i'm
actually making
just as much money renting them out room
by room but to the government of social
housing
then then renting them out to
professionals yeah so
you've got such peace of mind so we work
with a government
based contractor yeah they come to us
and say well okay
this area is open go shopping so what we
do is go
source source a property what's going to
pass a number of checks
then marry an investor two up with that
and then we get the development work as
well
you know that's where i've been this
morning doing a handover over in
liverpool hand over yesterday in crew
but i've got now another two started in
crew so
to me i like social housing because it's
yeah you're giving a bit back
and bought end to dates continuity money
coming in and it's just
it's a full hands-off investment you
know and it's like it's great end of
each month to see that money keep on
ticking in
how do you feel if you are giving a bit
back in what way
because i want people to do social
housing more in what way
are landlords that give their house up
how are they helping people so this one
what we're in
for example this is not a government
backed but it's um it's given to a
housing association which is for the
homeless
so the time we've finished it you know
with the finish what we're doing
it's giving a house to the homeless
people you know
the other week we did one in wigan um
and that was for the veterans
so you know same again that was first
for a five year lease
so we're linked into a lot of these
organizations to try and
yeah by giving people back you know the
veterans the homeless
you know and so forth so yeah they're
all like relatively decent
bathrooms yeah but they're good sizes
and how much
are you going to be able to rent these
out for these apartments
so we've already got agreed now on this
one so it's all seven
apartments now we've been all agreed up
for 500 pound per calendar month so
it's time well it's on a seven year
lease and it's seven of them so what's
that about three and a half grand
yeah that's it and if you're putting all
your money out
what are you expecting the interest
payments to be on the on
hold on this one no on the whole on the
whole building
um so obviously we refinance it
obviously 25 percent in
so we're estimating i think around about
four to five percent a little higher
than we want but
that's what i would think we're aiming
for yeah and and the value is going to
be about
550 years yeah so i'm trying to work out
i haven't got my calculator i'm just
interested i don't know if you've
already done the calculation but
so how much if you're making three and a
half thousand pound a month's turnover
how much profit are you expecting to be
making around around about
two six two seven that's good though and
that's guaranteed
seven year lease no cost no maintenance
no management yeah
totally guaranteed yeah but things can
change obviously with the covid
situation a lot of properties getting
down valued
so we're trying to go on the outside of
caution you know we don't over
over egg things it's not it is what it
is that's it
yeah but still even if you end up
leaving a little bit of money in you
know it's for seven years it's hands off
in there
it's you forget about it and you know
it's all your maintenance are picked up
unless the roof blows off for example
but yeah
there's no gas there's no water no
electric bills to pay or anything like
that so
also as well the thing i really like
about this kind of project
is you're helping people by giving back
by doing it social housing
but you're also helping the community by
turning an old rubbish office block
that's got structural issues it's being
it's being used for nothing
and you're turning it into a nice nice
affordable accommodation
which is really good for the economy
yeah so obviously in this area what
we're in
yeah it's not in the best areas but it's
in regeneration
so across you may have seen the old four
call some new houses are going to be
built there
so it is up and coming um especially
around this area in ashton
it's you're only like 20 25 minutes on
the metro link so you've literally got
the tram stop up the road
at the ikea stop there and it just goes
straight to city centre so
a lot of people forget about this area
this might a little bit of a tip it's
like my little hot spot
so here we are
this is a this is a big yeah big place
in here though
yeah it's also a bit of an open plain
kitchen like living room
at the same apartment yeah no that's the
same problem so that's the bedroom
through there so you've got seven
seven apartments and they're quite big
yeah they're all above 37
square meters seven big apartments for
125
000 pounds
um i'm really interested i'm really
curious i don't know
what you can say about this but in the
um
coal strategy of commercial to
residential
and i know we were talking off-camera
earlier about how why it's an exciting
thing
boris johnson easing the planning
permission bringing in more permitted
development
also offices going bust this
this was a business that went burst
wasn't it yeah that's right and not only
that
but this one was pre-covered but the
amount of
companies where they're going to be
letting their stuff work from home
offices are going to become more and
more unused
so talk to me about how you're taking
i know you're an opportunistic kind of
guy that's what you're an entrepreneur
what what are you thinking about the
whole strategy of commercial to
residential right now and what are you
looking to do
so obviously regardless of development a
lot of things haven't been confirmed yet
yeah um but i think i would say another
four weeks time we'll have a clear
understanding what's going to happen so
you know if you looked at this building
originally
it was completely shot nine times out of
ten a lot of people would have flattened
it where you'd have to apply for full
planning
with permitted development talks at the
moment it's not confirmed
you could get actually flatten it and
rebuild it you know under committed
development so
as yet that's still not confirmed but it
is interesting times
obviously through the covert situation
people now realize a lot of businesses
have gone right we can work from home
so they don't need these big glorified
offices that gives more opportunities
such as myself you know i'm actively
looking for more commercials
residentials
but i'll always do with subject to
planning offers so
you don't pay anything upfront you know
you only pay once you've got planning
approved
yeah so they're the kind of tactics what
we do and how do you lock in that
so if you're putting off a subject and
planning how do you lock that in so no
one else can come along and pinch it
before yeah so a lot of the estate
agents they may request 10
to be put down but that is refundable if
you don't get planning permission
and we've done one before where we've
paid nothing upfront
and it's all about getting a good
solicitor on board and working with
both parties communication is the key if
you haven't got communication you might
as well give up so
yeah what do you think um you know me
you know
that how i think about property i always
say property i think it's a people
business it's all about
communication it's about relationships
you being
very feet on the ground having builders
being a builder yourself what do you
think about that
yeah regarding especially in property
world it is a people business
it's um like i said before it's all
about the network
and you need the network to form a good
network is all about relationships so it
definitely is a people business it's
um you know it's like with the lads what
we've got we'll go out for a few drinks
we'll have meals together
we're just it sounds corny but we are a
family
you know we can rely on each other the
lads are very reliant on me that i keep
on giving the work they keep on
producing good quality
and it's just some you know a big cycle
what goes around we keep on producing
good quality projects
we're going to get more business what's
your biggest challenge at the moment i
think i know what you're going to say
but what's your biggest challenge
at the moment on the development side is
the materials but
one thing's what workers struggling on
is stock i thought that was what you're
gonna say lack of problems yeah
especially slackers properties because
we've got a number of investors
yes and they're hungry to buy yeah but
a lot of things at the moment are
overvalued you know
kovitz at the moment market value has
gone sky high
we've noticed an increase my personal
thoughts are in november i think we're a
little bit of a downturn yeah
that could be the time to start you know
spending your money but i'm saying that
while i'm going i'm buying one at the
moment
so i've never stopped buying no there's
knowing the right opportunity to do
some people do that some people are
constantly saying i'm gonna wait i'm
going to work i put a video on youtube
just yesterday where i said i actually
think there's going to be a bit of a
crash
on the property market in 2021 because
we're in a recession right now we
property is always the last thing to get
hit so i do think we're going to
probably
prices are going to drop with a mini
boom right now which is being
manufactured by the government
so but but at the same time and it
sounds like a bit of an oxymoron i still
think it's a good time to buy
because people that hold off as i went
for the perfect time away for the birth
time
what's going to happen you're just going
to leave the money in your bank or
there's no perfect time
no there's no but it's in my opinion
yeah um
every time you've got time to buy it's
knowing the right things to buy
yeah it's okay you know you can go buy
something completely
overvalued and above market value and it
might be a bad deal
but it's like i've got one going through
a sale at the moment it's only in
witness
not it's only a three bedroom terry's
property but i've picked it up for
really good money
and that's just long term i'm all about
long long long term
it's steady cash flow long-term gain and
it
builds a nice healthy pot again yeah
that's great
so this is apartment number three right
that's right
you've got seven apartments in total but
you've got
eight electrics so what what's the uh
rationale behind that
yeah so a lot of people don't basically
they overlook it
so in this area where we're stood this
literally meter by meter square this is
going to be like the communal space so
everyone can access
yeah you know the water meters the
electric points the gas are on the other
side
how many water points they've got seven
on there but then eight electrics
yeah because what you've got is a
landlord supply yeah so
yes it's a block of flats yeah
everyone's got it's got its own entrance
but here who's going to pay for the
lighting the smoke alarms
we've got outside lighting for the car
park to make it safe you know cctv's
going up as well
so that kind of thing so obviously
what's that going to run off is that
going to run off a flat so they have to
pay for it
so you have to have a landlord supply so
people do overlook that and they forget
about it but if you overlook it though
it's going to end up costing you more
money really isn't it
it's getting utilities in is a very slow
tedious job it doesn't happen overnight
and you have to get start getting things
organized from day one soon as you get
the keys you need to
action utilities yeah because nine times
out ten it'll take you six seven months
to get everything finished we're still
waiting for the meters to be installed
properly
you know and that's going back six seven
months ago takes ages
one of the things i like my biggest
advice to people that are in property
not just property development property
in general is things take forever
you need to have pay and i'm not a
patient person i'm very impatient but in
property
you just need to just expect things to
take forever and when the ball's in your
court
you've got to knock it out fast yeah but
when it's not in your court sometimes
you need to chase but sometimes you just
need to be patient
yeah but i won't add as well on this one
yes it is a block yes we've got each one
has got its own meter
but also we don't we can do it as a
title split later on so for whatever
reason we can sell them off individually
yeah so you know you can get one big
meter in then everything gets
fed off that one meter but then everyone
takes a shirt
in each apartment to basically pay for
it so that's where we
full saw it and do a bit of a title
split as well so we've
looked at it that doesn't help really
was it
so yeah we've looked at it and tried to
safeguard our clients as well as
ourselves say look we can title split
these at a later date
yes it costs a little bit more probably
an extra two and a half three thousand
pound
to get the old utilities in all on
separate meters yeah
but in the long term it's giving us
another exit how easy would it be to
split the tiles because you've already
got planning for seven apartments
so if you wanted to sell off the each
seven apartments because you're a
swifter
right and it's just straight forward you
can straight forward they'll split it up
with the help of the architects
obviously they'll do each layout of each
apartment go to the solicitors and
they'll they'll work there man
because you've you've you've done things
like this yeah it makes it much easier
yeah
just help just safeguard everything
although i assume you're not planning on
selling them off anytime soon because
you've got a seven year lease that's it
seven year leases attached to it so
passive income all the way that's it so
obviously there's no gas
to pay for no water no electric this is
going to be taken over by a housing
association
it saves them as well and management
because everything's in one area they
don't have to go around
so yeah it's a win-win really on this
one question would you rather get me
give you a million pounds in cash today
or 75 000 pounds a year in passive
income for the rest of your life i'll go
for passive all day long
most builders would probably want the
million yeah it's not
logical to go for yeah take the big
money quickly
but in the day before you know you can
go and blow that within 24 hours i like
that
continuity of money coming in a million
pounds in cash
today or a penny today
that doubles every day for the next
month
yeah it's the same again in tears you
just take the pen you want your eyes
because a penny that doubles every day
for a month will end up being more than
a million pounds considerably
which is just shocking well that's to me
it's all about the mindset
it's like if you're just focused on
money and quick money you'll go for the
million
but peop in property it's a long game
it's not a quick fix
yeah and they just have to take the time
and i always go for those lower amounts
and just get more of it
do you normally hold on to properties or
do you often
develop and then sell them or do you
often hold on to them me personally i
hold on to mine
and that's my game to build my pension
bottle
that's what it's all about um but some
people do flip it to me
in this current market it's not time to
flip especially up north it's not
yeah and down south you may get a good
one but um
no it's i like to keep all of them
i think you're quite a different most
builders that i meet are not like you
they're not wired in the way that you
are for investment for networking the
fact that you run it as a people
business the fact that you take the
the well wouldn't take the million you
take the passive income
what what do you think differentiates
your mindset to most people in this
profession
what differs me crikey i don't know i'm
just an older boy i'm going with a clue
but
um what why did you what why did you um
when you joined the academy for instance
yeah like what was your rationale behind
that you're already improving
you're already doing it because yes
i don't know everything far from it yeah
i know doing these kind of things i can
do this day in and day out
but it's the other strategies i haven't
got much knowledge on so yeah i knew
about lease options i didn't know about
how to go and structure one or go and do
things
ready to rent yeah i wanted to get
educated i basically had a little
bit of knowledge of everything yeah
development i knew a lot of
but little bits of knowledge of
everything well to me little bit of
knowledge is very dangerous
so you need to get a lot more knowledge
then you can start drawing your own
picture
so that's why i joined the academy and
to be honest at the academy what i've
benefited from is actually the network
of people
some great guys on there you know it's
um david taylor you may know
um so he's actually looking at a
property just up the road and which was
which was sourced for the client as well
and that could actually gdv around about
1.7 million because that's too big for
us
where david's got the capabilities of
doing it so that's where we'll just try
to marry him up with that
introduce them to the client so that's
very early days but um yeah it's the
network
it's it's invaluable to me yeah that's
awesome i i'm really grateful that
you've
you've shared so well because the great
thing about you and i said the same to
david taylor
is i really appreciate it when guys come
along to the training and stuff
but actually come to give as well as
just to get a lot of
my builders have been slowed down by
covid
and they've been two reasons why they've
been slowed down one is because
one of the contractors has got symptoms
yeah and this has caused the whole
nightmare
second thing is stock getting stuck
has been really difficult how have you
got around that as a developer having a
building company
yeah it's had its issues yeah the strict
procedures which we've had to put in
place with health and safety
and you know each morning staff has to
come in and basically science to say
haven't got any symptoms yes or no
if i pick up that someone's got it
basically they're isolated but
fortunately
on the jobs which we've got we've not
but i've had that many jobs on the go
i've safely put lads on inside
so they're not being inter-reacted as
much with this one
we had a lot of materials dropped on it
right at the beginning so everyone
buying toilet roll i was buying
materials so everyone else is buying
big rolls of pasta toilet rolls david's
there going actually i'm gonna buy
building materials and stuff yeah
i smart though so it's um we're always
trying to plan so
it's like me personally obviously we're
in manchester as we know
there could be the second lockdown
coming in this area i'm stocking up
again
so i'm just trying to think to safeguard
my clients who were doing the projects
for as well as myself
and then today you know your
reputation's only going to shine if you
basically think outside the box a bit so
yeah that's what we're doing
i love this place this this this would
be the apartment that i'd live in
because it's just more open
[Music]
um yeah it's all coming too we're not
we're not a million miles away
now what's been the biggest haul back
we'll pick up with it or is there not
been
yeah because of the major movement in it
we've gone we've had to
go in our contingency on this one we've
given it more contingency because of the
movement in the building
yeah so obviously all the flaws have
been re-leveled up you know
yes they're not bang on level with this
kind of aging property but they're all
flapped before you're up and uphill and
down in
how can you tell what are the telltale
signs that something's got structural
problems or
uh subsidence sounds different um you go
inside a property you can see how
your windows if they're moved your doors
for example if you shut the door and it
opens on its own
why usually you should shut it it stays
shut um
cracks on the elevations that kind of
thing
and look above you on the exercise look
on your head as your windows
if you can see something cracking yeah
i'm not talking about a small hairline
i've got major cracks you know
if it's cracked through a full brick
that takes a lot of force to crack a
full break
this could be an underlying issue you
know nine times that tendon there will
be
if you see major man a state agent's
favorite saying
um is it it is a bit of sometimes it's a
bit
i think it's historical yeah the
movement
it's just just basically general
movement in there it's all settled now
yeah that's what you get and yeah nine
times out of ten it could be
but then there's only that one percent
chance where it may not be so what do
you do if you're a bit unsure
if you feel like you're on a boat yeah
with this stage and saying oh
it should be okay we think it's
historical just a bit of movement
how do you find out basically just come
here you know of course getting the
right people in place
it always comes back to this the thing
is david i am not an expert
in in every single avenue of property i
don't know
all the building lingo sometimes but the
thing is it doesn't matter
because i've got a really good team so
i'll just bring someone in i'll bring an
expert here an expert there an expert
there
what's i don't know you you're a bit of
an expert
but you do the same you bring in in
teams how do you do that how do you get
those relationships and how do you bring
in those experts
it's how i've got my team together
basically is um
recommendations yeah i always speak
volumes for me
so you know social engineers and you
know building control
all come from recommendations but
networking events yeah you know it's
like i've
i've stopped doing it don't get me wrong
for the last what year
um i've not been to many but that's how
i really
drummed up the business really for
myself yeah and also talking to people
you know meeting up for coffee is that
kind of thing it's certainly it's what
it's all about i say it's people
business end of the day
and how do you know what the envelope
project is going to be what do you do
with that like you i know you've got an
estimation that this is going to be
about 5
5 15 once it's finished where's that
come from you just guess
no so we've got we work with a number of
uh independent
surveyors so we have talks with them
saying we're going to be doing this to
this property
what do you think you can achieve yeah
we don't just get one we get two
yeah so we get two opinions and then
usually we just go stop bang in the
middle
yeah and you actually pay them to come
and give you an actual end valuation
yeah that's it
and do you find that sometimes they can
differ a lot or uh
on this one it's not been too bad but on
others we have yeah um
something so again on one project gdp
was down about 600 000
yeah we did get great big variations um
on that so they the variations of which
is about 50 60 000 which is a big gap
for something of that size
yeah when we tried to piece the puzzle
together and go why
is because one we found out one didn't
have as much knowledge on the
development of what we were doing
so it was it was our fault for not
giving us more information on the
project
getting some knowledge bombs out there
aren't we cold have we didn't play
every day so dave tell me what are the
top few things
you'd look for in turning a commercial
property into a residential property
what are you looking for basically i'm
something like this i look at
the size of the building what you can do
with it so good size it always
makes makes me look at it and go right
that's going to really work yeah
car park facilities if you've got a car
park nine times that time that's going
to go through planning quite
smoothly and look at the general areas
it would regeneration area
or is it just going to be a nice little
snug you know additional two-bedroom
terrace what you can put on the end of a
plot
generally build up a bigger picture use
your network and basically
get that team together and once you've
got that your size
you know your car park facilities and
the area once you've got them three
things
you should be start moving the right
direction and
you always say you talk about the power
of relationships you talk about the
power of education
talk to me about is this a good strategy
that people should be looking at or do
you think this is a very difficult thing
that most people should just be staying
away from
it's with this kind of development it's
not i want personally it's not for
beginners to go straight in and i think
i'm going to do that straight off the
back
i agree basically it's a slow process
yeah so how i've learned
my trick of the trade was basically by
simple buy to let's
yes get get a good footing so basically
building a property in effect
yeah of like okay building a foundation
with a simple buy to let's
do your basic refurbishment so you can
start doing bigger things
and then once you progress you can move
on it's um what are the dangers
of starting out and biting off more than
you can chew because i t
you know you've been through my whole
training process i always teach
buy to that to start with yeah that's
and then and then we move on to things
that are a bit more advanced brr
and and this sort of stuff not that this
is massive but
it can go wrong so what are some of the
risks and some of the dangers
of jumping into a development on your
own with the wrong not the right
education with not the right people
around you what could go wrong
basically you're just going to lose a
lot of money it's um your wallet's going
to end up very empty very very quickly
if you don't use the right people
yeah and if you don't use the right
people then you're on the hiding to
nothing in my opinion
so you think start with buy to let maybe
or start small and get bigger and bigger
obviously it comes with your confidence
you know it's like i'm going back
or about six seven months ago there's
certain aspects i haven't done
within my business yes i had to i've got
a good education i've
learned and read things and it's like
okay then i'll ever do it so it's like
simple things loft conversions you know
they're not a straightforward piece of
thing to do
yeah you know you have to have the right
people to do that loft conversion split
properties up
do title splits yeah just we ease
yourself into it very very slowly don't
rush into it
love it so someone watching this video
right now number one piece of advice
that you can leave them with
go number one advice well basically
form your power team get your network
together and then once you've got that
basically you should be flying and
basically knowledge is power
it sounds so corny when i say it but it
is knowledge is the way i only knew a
little bit of everything everything
yes i'm not a master but i know a lot
more than i did it's really easy people
like you that have been in the game for
a long time
to almost be a bit a bit prideful and to
say i don't need to learn i don't need
to
but i always admire people because
actually i've been in the game a long
time but i'm still going to go and
attend the class i'm still going to read
the book i'm still going to sit with
this person that person
and pick their brains and i think that's
one of the reasons why you're continuing
to grow from strength to strength
so mad respect good to see you in action
guys if you enjoyed that video please do
smash the like button don't forget to
subscribe
also there's another video a bit similar
that you might like right here
and you can subscribe right here i look
forward to seeing you
next time